I'm very pleased to announce the new
partnership between Westwood One America's
largest audio network and the Jordan B.
Peterson podcast with the premier
episode release this Sunday,
March 24th subsequent podcasts will be
released every Sunday featuring lectures
about issues of profound psychological
and social importance and discussions
with leading scientists,
philosophers and authors.
I'm also very happy that I will be joined
in this revised podcast by my daughter,
Mikayla Peterson,
who will serve as cohost and discuss it.
It's a project we have both been excited
to develop and they're looking forward
to continually improving.
We hope that the Westwood one partnership
will improve the quality of our
production and introduce many
new listeners to the podcast.